we're exploring how robots can transform
the way we live and work this week in a
robotics revolution series an estimated
38 percent of American jobs are at high
risk of automation by the early 2030s
some cities like Las Vegas will be hit
hard
research shows that nearly two-thirds of
all Las Vegas jobs may be automated by
2035
but what if machines could be a natural
extension of us Nina Jacobson introduces
us to two robots potentially
transforming the workforce
Dayna good morning good morning mit
hosted the brightest minds in tech
yesterday showing off the latest in
artificial intelligence and robotics one
of the most notable and
multi-dimensional advances is a way for
humans and robots to safely join forces
we met one robot who works side by side
with people
another uses brain control to take cues
from humans in order to complete tasks
both bots are changing the workplace as
we know it so who or what am I looking
at here well this is our great
innovation you mean which means you and
me and it allows robots to work
hand-in-hand with human beings you me is
what's called a CO bot a new breed of
collaborative robot that could
revolutionize the assembly line you me
makes paper airplanes solves the rubik's
cube and even helps a person with
multiple sclerosis play chess and this
is Baxter a brain controlled robot that
could help humans think more and do less
one idea that we kind of thought about
was well can the Baxter robot help a
human assemble IKEA furniture or
something like we all would love that at
MIT is computer science and artificial
intelligence lab Stephanie Gill and
Andre Salazar are developing robots like
Baxter who can learn from his mistakes
by reading your brainwaves and
transmitting your thoughts
I wear the calf I look at the robot
doing a task he's doing it wrong and I'm
just thinking he picked up the leg and
not the arm and suddenly something's
transmitted to the robot the researchers
assure us they are not teaching robots
to read our minds
imagine a world with many robots but the
labs director daniela ruse imagines the
possibility of someday seeing man and
machine work hand in hand a machine
would be able to read more radiology
scans in a day then the physician will
see in a lifetime but the machine will
not have the same kind of creativity so
I like to think of machines and people
as working together machines doing what
they're best at and people doing what
they're best at not everyone thinks it's
a match made in heaven
Tesla CEO Elon Musk recently warned that
artificial intelligence poses an
existential threat to humanity Ramos
will be able to do everything better
than us I mean I'm cleaning I mean all
of us you know Elon Musk said it if we
don't regulate artificial intelligence
it's a danger for mankind for humankind
what do you think you can't stop
technology from evolving and from
changing the world but we can anticipate
the changes and we can put the rules in
place to make sure that the changes are
for the better you will take a lot of
time for a robot to become human-like so
a robot to do this interview with you
and go and then take a cab back home you
know that that will take decades Samy
attea is the president of robotics in
motion at ABB the company that developed
yume that collaborative industrial robot
I think what is important is that
artificial intelligence is used as a
tool and it's not a means by itself all
the experts that we talked with over
this past week reminded us that
technological advancement isn't new
we've seen it over time from the
Agricultural Revolution to the invention
of the spreadsheet and they say as
artificial intelligence games steam and
blue-collar manufacturing jobs disappear
we have to remember that we have to
retrain those workers to compensate but
the revolution will happen you can find
jobs it's just the training needs to be
there and they certainly encourage it
from a very young age teaching
technology and code yes and teaching
them to code the way you would teach a
language to a child early on so it's a
part of their being it's interesting to
see the debate within the industry as
well as to how advanced they should go
exactly and everybody did also say that
idea
Galatian is so important because of that
we need to regulate and remember that we
can control these BOTS Dana thank you
thank you well our series robotics
revolution continues tomorrow with a
look at machines like Robo mowers that
are taking over mundane tasks at home I
like that I can say Nick one teenagers
around the world rejoicing